The en,
the police investigation
in the case of naturalization applications
or of French nationality
in general is mandatory.
On the other hand,
maintenance,
is not mandatory.
I explain,
in fact,
many of you think that
they were not summoned by the gendarmerie
or by the national police,
that there was no investigation that was done,
the investigation may have been done without your knowledge,
so in truth without your knowledge,
and in 1 certain case
the national police go directly to your home
to see if you are already there or not,
and to ask you questions afterwards.
And in other cases,
she has your phone number
because it is transmitted through architecture,
she uh calls you,
she gives you 1 appointment
to go to the gendarmerie.
Then it is necessary to know that in the gendarmerie
or the national police,
we ask you some questions of order,
uh. Practical,
like knowing,
um.
Why you want to become French,
do you
know a little about the history of France,
why France and not our country?
We have some really basic questions,
so there's nothing to worry about.
So if it's in the
as part of an application for declaration by marriage,
we can ask you the question about your uh.
Your relationship with your wife,
your meeting place,
your meeting date,
the date of birth of your children et cetera
Et cetera. But know that,
in any case,
there is no complexity
for uh.
For that kind of request.